plus de 1300 agents travaillent ici sur
la recherche agronomique 70 ans que
l'inra étudie agriculture alimentation
et environnement pour cet anniversaire
le centre de versailles grignon a ouvert
ses portes au public
une après-midi de visite consacrée à
l'intensification de la production
agricole l'agriculture les c'est la
jauge avait pas mal de pollution aux
particules et pour tout que cette
pollution pesticides donc l'origine
c'est bien mais c'est vraiment agricole
donc il faut réagir et on réagit à
différents niveaux nous on est en haut
niveau ce python réagir des points de
vue leurs sièges pour quelles méthodes
ont collaboré quel système des cultures
du système de production diminuer notre
dépendance à l'utilisation des
pesticides donc on essaie de diminuer
les doses
fondée en 1946 l'inra avait pour mission
de trouver comment nourrir la france
après la guerre un objectif atteint dans
les années 70 depuis la recherche a
évolué vers une agriculture durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement
des appareils qui sont ici mesure les
concentrations en gaz à effet de serre
en polluants atmosphériques
mais pas seulement les concentrations ce
qu'on mesure surtout ce qu'ils sont ou
spécifiques ici c'est qu'on mesure des
émissions et les dépôts de ces composés
on sait que si on stocke plus de carbone
on va augmenter les émissions de
protoxyde d azote qui est au ciel
gaz à effet de serre donc il faut
trouver la bonne combinaison de
pratiquer imaginer les systèmes de
culture qui permettent de vraiment
trouver le meilleur compromis pour
résoudre pas seulement un problème et un
panel de problèmes l'an dernier l'inra a
déposé une trentaine de brevets afin de
protéger ses recherches le centre de
versailles grignon organise toute
l'année des conférences pour présenter
son travail en mail accueillera des
lycéens pour la journée internationale
de célébration des plantes